NEW IRONMAN OF THE NATIONAL
HOCKEY LEAGUE.
>> AND THAT'SFICIAL FOR KEITH Y
OUT THERE WEARING GREEN AND
WHITE AND
OPPORTUNITY, GREAT START FOR THE
ISLANDERS, CLUTTERBUCK, MARTIN
GO TO WORK, AND WE HIGHL
DEALING WITH LINE,
AND THAT'S ONE YOU WANTndan: TH.
LINDBLOM AND SANDIN DID GET
ASSISTS ON THE GOAL 57 SEF THE
DROUGHT.
POWER PLAY WAS CLICKING SO WELL.
SCORED GOTTEN TO.
>> SO MUCH RESPECT.
I WAS A LITTLE NERVOUS IN N HEA
KEEP MARCHING ON AND PLAY
THROUGH SO MUCH.
>>
>> Brendan: HIS TEAM PLAYED LAST
NIGHT AGAINST DALL
>> Brendan: BEFORE IT GOT TO VAN
RIEMSDYKYK  P HEARD ME.
ANOTHER ONE THERE, AND HERS WIT.
>> Butch: THEY'RE A JUGGERNAUT.
BARRY TREY, NOW
IT'S DOBSON, SET UP CHARA ONCE
ADMINISTER, CHARA,
40 SECONDS LEFT ON THE POWER
PLAY.
GOAL ON PARISE, BARZAL SCORES.
BT
ONE AS I MENTIONED RIGHT UP IN
THE TOYE FOR
WAHLSTROM, TOOK A HACK THERE,
LOST CONTROLHELMET.
>> Butch: HE'S SMILING ON THE
BENCH. LOT OF SKATING,
DON'T THE LEDGE, PAST
YORKRK PELECH.
PROVOROV DIN.
DOESN'T LOOK AS NO
CHANCE FOR SOROKIN.
HE IN THE
CORNER.
>> Brendan: CLUTTERBUCK TOOK AN
AWKWARDD THE LINE, FOR
BEAUVILLIER, PARISE SCORES.
PAS
TO PARISE, AND LIKED THE WAY TH
KILLED THE PENALTY.
DIDN'T ICE WIN